bei uns gibt es hier gerade Mittagessen
und wir hatten noch alte Nudeln im
Kühlschrank das heißt eine Portion voll
die gestern nicht gegessen wurde sieht
momentan ein bisschen unappetitlich aus
das sind diese kleinen Kritharaki Nudeln
und ich zeige euch mal wie ihr die jetzt
ein bisschen aufpeppen könnt am nächsten
Tag ich nehme dafür etwas Olivenöl das
kommt jetzt in die Pfanne die habe ich
ein bisschen klein geschnittener Paprika
die wird kurz angebraten
dann ein bis zwei Esslöffel
paprika-markt oder wenn es nicht so
scharf sein soll Tomatenmark dazu
die Nudeln mit reingeben
mit etwas Wasser auffüllen und
gerne noch Kräuter dazu und wer es
richtig cremig haben möchte gibt jetzt
noch einen Schuss Sahne dazu oder auch
gerne Schmand Frischkäse alles was Sie
an Milchprodukten offen habt und dann
gerne noch Mozzarella drüber